in this video i want to break down the
difference between branding and direct
response marketing and why not deeply
understanding the differences costing
you millions and millions of dollars and
ultimately the amount of money that you
probably want to make and if you don't
know who i am my name is alex mozy i own
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that is about 85 million
dollars a year in revenue and i have
nothing to sell you all right i make
these videos because i was once broke
and i've learned a lot of lessons on the
way and i don't want the pain that i
experienced to be in vain that's why i
make these so that being said branding
versus direct response i think this is
one of the more interesting topics that
i have dove into over the last year or
so and it's come from a variety of
different conversations i've had with
top marketers and this morning i had a
conversation with dean graciosi who
is a phenomenal world-class marketer and
we talked for like an hour this morning
just about this concept of the
difference between branding and direct
response and i thought i would share
some of the the lessons or discussion
points that we had with you so that you
can hopefully benefit and so the first
point is that you may have heard this in
in my book 100 million offers but the
longer you delay the ask the bigger the
ask can be uh so for example you know if
you're if you can use this in any
situation whether you're you know
courting a a lady or a guy or whatever
you know if in the first five seconds
you're like hey let's go home together
it's like well you might have some
audience to be willing to do that but
the vast majority of people would not be
willing to do that but if you date for
you know six months then that might be
something that would be almost everybody
would be willing to do that after six
months depending on whatever really
beliefs that's not my point here but you
can get the idea that a higher and
higher percentage people would be
willing to take you up on an offer if
they spend more and more time with you
and so the longer the delay the bigger
the ask and the visual that i like to
ascribe to this is the the longer the
runway the bigger the plane that can
take off and so the bigger the payload
you can get based on the amount you
delay to the same degree if you've seen
um garyvee he's he's uh he's an
influencer and and he owns a marketing
agency out of new york and he spent i
want to say 10 years or 12 years
building his personal brand and then he
finally had his ask which was hey buy my
nft and then within the span of you know
six months ended up making like a
hundred million dollars from that nft
launch right now i would make the
argument that the nft launch itself was
actually direct request marketing play
whereas everything prior to that was
really about building the brand
different examples of this that i think
would be important to drive the point
home and why i think that many many many
marketers start in direct response and
then end up in branding is because of
one about to share with you so please
listen closely to this if you are trying
to make more money if you look at most
big consumer brands you look at you know
colgate or crest or you know shampoo
brands right that have been here for a
very long time they're not offering
two-for-one deals they're not like hey
go buy this toothpaste for 50 off right
that's not actually what they're doing
they're just talking about the products
and if you look at some of these bigger
celebrities that exist you look at
dwayne johnson the rock built his huge
brand and then said hey i'm i'm offering
i'm i'm starting this tequila guy you
guys should check it out colin mcgregor
conor mcgregor built up you know his
personal brand then said hey check out
proper 12. kylie jenner was like hey
built up her brand and then she did her
lip kits and so what's interesting is
that brand people are now realizing is
an amazing arbitrage opportunity for
maximizing value and i think part of the
reason behind this is that goodwill
compounds faster than revenue does and
so hear me out think through this with
me if you've seen somebody who's
consistently been selling and this may
be you what happens is you provide value
in some way and then you extract the
value that you've the equity in the
relationship through monetizing it
through an ask or some sort of right
hook as they say just getting them to
try and buy something right and the
thing is is that whenever you make an
ask you decrease your goodwill right and
so you kind of have to start over at
zero again and then you build up
goodwill and then you and you ask and
then it goes back to zero again right so
you're constantly depositing and
extracting uh capital in the
relationship and the hope is that it
costs you less the deposit than you make
on the extraction right like that's
fundamentally what like traditional
direct response marketing is at its most
basic form right and the reason it is
direct response is that we are actively
requesting a direct reply or immediate
action as a result of seeing our
advertisement right of any kind to
contrast that with branding what we're
doing with branding is that we are
reinforcing the values and the stories
that people tell about our products and
services all right so we're reinforcing
stories versus asking for actions and
you might be like well i you know
branding doesn't make sense and i want
to tell you this because when i started
out my career i thought that every
single company that did branding was
[ __ ] i was like you guys are idiots
if you guys understood how direct
response worked you guys would make more
money i'm such a genius blah blah blah
blah and i was wrong as i often am and
the more i studied these massive
companies i was like okay so all of
these companies all do this type of
marketing whereas little old me is doing
this quick you know jab right hook
whatever mark of just of just give ask
give ask give this give ask and always
just you know depositing enough value in
order to extract the value later and the
thing is is people get it people have
seen it they know the game and yes it
does work to a limited degree right but
it's very very rare to find a massive
massive direct response company i'm not
saying they don't exist but i would say
the preponderance of enormous companies
are not direct response based companies
and so why is that and i would pause it
and this is my theory and this is what i
talked to dean this morning about at
length is the difference between direct
response and branding is not the roi on
the advertisement itself but on the time
horizon with which we measure it all
right and so in direct response you're
always calculating your return on ad
spend immediately rather than thinking
can i build up this brand and then look
at the return you're getting on that
brand overall over an extended period of
time and so i'll give you a classic
example to illustrate the difference if
i were selling t-shirts a direct
response marketer might have a cool
funny meme thing aggressively market it
have upsells of two of two of the same
shirts five of the same shirts getting
on continuity for each meme shirt every
month blah blah blah blah right that
would be a typical direct response
marketing playing not so you can't make
money doing it you can and that's this
is the big exception i'm having here
right is that like you can become a
millionaire doing
small games all right so i'm not saying
you can't do it you absolutely can it's
just that what type of game would you
prefer to play and i can say that as
i've i've aged or weathered in the game
i continue to shift more and more
towards branding but i do think there's
a balance that needs to be struck but
from a from a branding perspective in
that same example it would be spending a
year talking about what your values are
the the stories that you want people to
tell about you and your company and then
you can simply put your brand on a
t-shirt and people will pay a hundred
dollars for it right and so then what is
the return on the advertising you did
for that year well if you can sell
t-shirts for a hundred dollars rather
trying to rather than trying to
arbitrage you know meme t-shirts and
discounts and bundling and doing all
sorts of more complex things and just
simply saying if you believe what we
believe vote with your dollars about the
things that you care about align with us
and that's fundamentally what branding
is when branding works very well is when
what you are saying about your brand
clarifies what people are already saying
and so a lot of times people have a
general gist of what your brand is
hopefully it's what you want oftentimes
it's not and this is especially true in
the direct response marketing community
at large because people say terrible
things about the people who are doing
their drug response and so their brand
is the reputation and the things that
other people say about you right and an
example that elon musk gave in interview
i can't remember where he gave it he
talked about how the consumer is the one
that creates your brand he said if you
look at i think he gave the example of
toyota and ford but the point is not
necessarily the brands but more so the
message which is he said listen you know
ford talked about being reliable and
being high quality etc he said in toyota
their marketing never said that and yet
toyota is the company that's known for
being reliable and high quality and
things like that compared to the fords
right he said so as much you can say
whatever you want in the in the
marketing messaging but it has to be
true and so to my interpretation of that
is what you want to do is give people
the words to describe your brand that
are true and just give them the words to
say rather than trying to redefine the
thoughts they have and i think that that
is really what comes to effective
branding and doing that deliberately as
an added point to that this is something
that i got from grant cardone which has
been one of one of the really deep and
profound lessons i think i got from our
two conversations we've had about
marketing in general but one first off
the many people who who don't like grant
you have to appreciate how effective he
is at promoting himself and his brand
like you have to respect that all right
you can you cannot like the man but you
can act you must respect what his his
level of effort and the outcome and the
output of his effort right i personally
have had nothing but positive
interactions with the grant but my point
is is that you have to respect that now
that being said one of the things that
he said that i have really taken with me
is the one or two words that someone
will associate with your brand he said
when they think of me i want them to
think this right and that is not
uh you know this massive declarative you
know value statement or mission
statement because people don't care
right nor do they remember
hardly anything and so if you can get
the masses to just remember oh yeah he's
the real estate guy he's the business
builder guy right which should be more
aligned with what we do we build
businesses and we you know we buy
interest in in in information coaching
e-learning type businesses that are in a
niche and like that's what i want people
to associate now they're not going to
remember all the stuff that i just said
but if i can just if they can just say
like he's a digital business builder
like he or like this digital business
investor right either of those things
would be things that i would say okay
that's a positive association that's the
type of association that i want people
to make with my brand right and the
thing is is that if i can wait a longer
time which is why most people cannot do
this and why i'm not saying you
necessarily have to start branding day
one but if you can be cognizant of what
the message that you were relaying in
your content and in the advertising that
you do and i'm using advertising by the
actual definition which is to make known
right when you when you make your
products and services known in the many
ways that you do it if you can reinforce
the simple message in every single
thing people will begin as long as it's
aligned with what's true
to say the same things back to you and
that will reinforce the cycle of who you
are in the marketplace and what you
stand for and so if branding is a higher
roi activity overall i believe it is and
i think that there's the many massive
companies that exist out there would be
great testaments and evidence to that
point is that they don't engage in
direct response marketing for the most
part or even at all
to the vast
like the vast majority of the time they
are talking much more about who they are
and what they stand for right why they
do what they do right and then people
then buy their products and service in
accordance with their values and they
vote with their dollars but the things
that they care about being the identity
that they wish to associate with right
and so i think that the reason seth
godin started with direct response and
then became and now talks exclusively
about branding the reason simon's index
started direct response and then talks
way more about branding the reason that
i started in direct response and talked
much more about uh branding stuff now
and at least that's my belief in where i
think it's because that's where you make
more money
just over a longer time horizon and i
think the reason that many direct
response marketers burn out is because
they don't like the brand that they are
building for themselves which is why
most people leave the space over a long
enough time horizon and so that's why
you don't see many i'm not saying there
aren't any but the vast majority of
direct response marketers tend to be
younger one of the difficult things
about this and i was having a good
conversation with a friend about this is
that because it is such a young space
there are no there are not many people
who have old lessons the the predominant
education that exists in the space is
people who are new the fact that someone
can consider themselves a quote og in
the internet marketing space after three
years is laughable right it's laughable
it's hilarious but it's true in that
space it's very difficult to be an og
because most people burn out because
their brand equity drops so much
right and so if the only way that we can
build very big things is doing them the
same thing over a long period of time
then it would create the i don't say
obvious but a natural conclusion that
branding is the direction that more
people end up going in once they have
the ability to do so and so if you can
delay the ask and you can have the
resources and you can have the patience
to build something bigger your goodwill
will compound faster
than your revenue will in a direct
response marketing environment and so
this is the concept around give give
give rather than ask give give give
comma give give give comma give give
give
get and what's interesting is that i
think most people
and the prospects that are consuming
your your content and things like that
they are waiting for the other shoe to
drop they're waiting for you to make the
ask and so they have their guard up but
if you give give give
and then right when they're expecting
you to ask give again and then again and
give even more
their guard begins to drop and then they
start to think man
this guy or this gal
is awesome i really like this person and
then something interesting happens they
start telling people about you because
they don't believe that they're
sacrificing their own brand equity by
sharing your message that is where the
compounding effects of word of mouth
start to take off and so when i say that
goodwill compounds faster than revenue
it's because in the traditional example
it would be give give give ask and this
isn't me poo poo and gary or anything
like that i mean i think that
very much at least establishing that
cadence is useful for most people who
are doing a response direct response at
least give something before you ask
right but if rather than asking right
where you have to start over at zero
because you build you build equity you
build value in the relationship and then
you asking you back down to zero and
then you build it then you go back down
to zero and then you're basically always
capped by the amount of
value that you have in the relationship
that's the cap right
but the alternative if you were to look
at this visually would be give give give
give give give give give and then it
keeps going the chart keeps going off
and then at a certain point a certain
percentage of that audience because they
have they are reciprocal in nature type
people they will take steps towards you
without you even asking simply because
they believe so strongly in what you
have and those the types of clients
right that you want to be able to take
on it just takes patience to get there
but when you have those types of clients
they get better results they pay bigger
premiums and it also gives you implied
scarcity within your products and
services and you're always underselling
your demand which will essentially
eliminate your bottleneck that you have
in growing because you always have more
demand than you can possibly handle and
that is the benefit of building the
brand over the long term rather than
simply the the one two punches in order
to extract capital today and so if you
can delay the amount of time that you
have between when you provide value and
when you ask and ideally you never do
you simply allow the goodwill to
continue to compound allow the word of
mouth to continue to grow to the point
where you start receiving money probably
far far further in the future than you
are now and what you are accustomed to
doing but in that future state you can
then look at the minimal amount that
you're spending right in order to
distribute your message to advertise
right to make known and then you will
see that you have significantly higher
returns on your advertising efforts it
just took longer to get there and so
understanding the difference between
branding and direct response and having
a longer term perspective and looking at
the ogs in the space or lack thereof and
they're people who have transitioned
from direct response to branding i think
that there is a lot of lessons that we
can take from it and this is just one of
them that i wanted to share with you and
if you're new to the channel welcome to
mozi nation um i said this earlier but
our portfolio is about 85 million a year
it's actually a little higher than that
i just try to stay consistent but i
think it's probably over 100 now but i i
make these videos because i struggled a
lot coming up and i and i just i hope
that you know the pain that i went
through is not for nothing and so that's
why i make these videos so we we
i just i just hope you like it so
anyways keep being awesome and i'll see
you guys the next fit